This first div has content
saying semantics, but
it also has an aria-hidden attribute.
However, the aria-hidden attribute
doesn't have an explicit value.
So, this element isn't actually
hidden from assistive technology.
So it has a label, Semantics.
This span has a role of checkbox and
is area labeled by an element with
an ID of label which is right below it.
The element it's labeled by is hidden.
However, area-labeledby may refer
to elements which are hidden.
So this gets a label of Styling.
This button has a hidden attribute which
causes it to be explicitly not rendered,
so it has no label.
And this span has a roll of button and
contains another span with the role
of image and an area label of menu.
Since the outer span
contains the inner span,
It uses its computed
label as its contents.
So it ends up with a label of menu.